la vidéoprotection toujours plus
présente toujours plus sophistiquées des
caméras gérés par des policiers pour
lutter contre la délinquance
une idée qui est née à roubaix en 1990
souris et mesdames vous êtes filmés et
pas seulement par fr3 la police
municipale elle aussi vous épie c'était
une promesse du maire andré diligent
lors de sa campagne en 1983
l'insécurité la violence ne s'arrête pas
aux anciens docks 3 et puis je crois
qu'il y a sur le plan matériel
un certain nombre de techniques
nouvelles à rechercher ces nouvelles
techniques douces caméras déployées dans
le centre ville à l'époque aucune loi
n'encadre et la vidéosurveillance et les
habitants étaient mitigées ça s'est très
bien passé que c'est un bon moyen de
lutter contre la délinquance à roubaix
au disney là-haut non ce propos après à
peine 6 mois d'utilisation
la délinquance n'avait pas diminué du
centre-ville de roubaix
l'expérience pilote des caméras de
surveillance partout dans la ville pour
la police municipale ne semble donc pas
avoir donné les résultats escomptés
malgré ce constat peu probants une autre
ville se lance dans l'aventuré trois ans
plus tard en 1993 cette ville c'est
levallois perret et son maire c'est
patrick balkany qui faisait la promotion
des caméras de vidéosurveillance bien
maintenant un sentiment d'insécurité
pour les
les agresseurs potentiels et je crois
qu'ils ne viennent pas trop sur sur
levallois c'est une bonne chose ils font
ils font attention mais en plus nous
allons maintenant tripler le nombre de
caméras par rapport à ceux déjà
installés
aujourd'hui de nombreuses communes sont
équipées de systèmes vidéo qu'on appelle
désormais vidéoprotection et le débat
autour de l'efficacité d'un tel système
est toujours d'actualité
entre les pros et antis vidéoprotection
[Musique]